over the last five years forget about
even the election the enormous minority
of unhappy people in our society are
dramatically louder and are impacting us
more than the far majority of us that
are happy and good there's only so much
I can do about being happy and
documenting my happy journey I'm trying
to pressure the other people that are
happy to talk about it too
I just think we're in a very awkward
time I think it's rubbernecking and it's
just the way it is right like we pay
more attention to the negative than the
positive it's just how I feel about the
world like I think I think human beings
are the most underrated thing of all
time when I think about our capabilities
to eliminate each other
I'm being serious I know it's kind of a
weird place to go but like the fact that
we're still here we are hardwired in a
way that allows us to protect each other
in a net game yet the mainstream media
and the way we hear all you hear is
negativity all that mainstream media
does is tell us about the point zero
zero zero one percent worst of us I
think we as humans are going to have
some level of a sense of responsibility
that if you're in a good place it might
be good to tweet or Instagram or
snapchat about that versus what we
default into which is there are people's
Twitter feeds that are basically every 7
or 10 days when they're complaining
about an airline or venting about work
like the volume of negativity is just
way too high in reality of what's going
on and I think the silent majority of us
and this is what happens every Empire
Falls when the silent majority of happy
isn't loud enough
you